I'm Aaron Shaffer.
I work on our global brand solutions team.
I'm a part of the broader youtube crew.
So let me tell you a little bit about Ariana.
I'm sure many of you already know a lot of this.
Um,
but Arianna is the cofounder precedent at an an editor and chief of Huffington
Post's media group.
She launched the Huffington post in 2005 and in 2012 the slight won a Pulitzer,
the first for a digital media company.
Incredibly impression for their national reporting.
Arianna also in all her free time has been a very busy author.
She's the author of 15 books and her 15th and most recent that we're going to
talk a little bit about today is the sleep revolution,
which is about the science,
history and mystery of sleep.
Um,
and I know we'll dig into that a bit.
You also probably know that Ariana has been named to times magazine's list of
the hundred most influential people and the Forbes most powerful women list.
She's on numerous boards,
including the center for public integrity and Uber.
And she's also originally from Greece having moved to England when she was 16,
um,
where she graduated from Cambridge with a Master's,
an MBA in economics.
And again,
I've only had the pleasure of meeting her just this morning,
but I already feel that we're close friends after 15 minutes.
She's a very,
very special person.
So with that area on a please come on up.
[inaudible]
so thank you so much for joining us here.
Yeah,
and I'm so happy that everybody seems to be getting a copy of the sleep
revolution.
Yes,
we're sorry.
Not Everybody on GVC can do that,
but um,
but was two should get a copy of the book.
Um,
so what I'll do is I'll ask you a few questions and then I'll open it up to our
audience here and then the many people who've asked questions from around the
globe on our dory.
But let me get started here and I'd love to start with this book and the sleep
revolution.
So can you tell us a bit about your motivation for writing a book about sleep?
So,
um,
my motivation was that I actually collapsed from sleep deprivation and I'm on my
way down,
broke my cheekbone,
a corner of my desk.
And as I came to in a pool of blood,
and I had to ask myself the question,
if you come to in a pool of blood and nobody has showed you,
is that really what success looks?
And so that led to a book I wrote two years ago called thrive and,
and in thrive sleep is a tiny part.
And as I went around the world speaking about redefining success and including
our wellbeing and sense of wonder and giving into the definition,
what people really wanted to talk about was sleep because it was Sherry.
It's like it's the universal common denominator.
You know,
you may not want to meditate or wonder or give,
but you have to sleep.
So I decided to sort of dig deep and make the book very much based on all the
latest science about sleep because it's kind of amazing.
Sleep is a very new science.
In fact,
the first,
a scientific slip center was founded here at Stanford in 1970 and now there are
over 2,500 in the US alone.
And the conclusion,
as you'll see,
the 1200 scientific footnotes in the book,
you don't have to actually read them,
but if you have a partner or a friend who's skeptical about sleep,
you can make them read them because it's kind of unequivocal and conclusive.
The science Dezeen sleep is not negotiable.
Um,
it's not something you can choose to do or not do unless you have a genetic
mutation.
And about 1% of the population has a genetic mutation and they can do great on
four or five hours sleep.
I don't have the genetic mutation and you cannot train yourself to have a
genetic mutation,
but there is actually a choice before your children are born.
You have to chill.
But if you,
and we'll have a third one and you want them to be a short sleeper.
I don't know why you would,
but if you do,
you can do gene editing before the baby's born.
Once the baby's born,
the days gas,
that's tit,
seven to nine hours where you are in that spectrum is individual but seven to
nine.
So what is the revolution itself?
So therefore solution is really changing the culture because we are all living
under the collective delusion.
And you experienced it more than anywhere here in the valley that,
um,
in order to succeed you have to burn out.
It's like that's the delusion of our culture.
I mean,
you go into companies and you see people being congratulated for working 24,
seven people were being,
being busy like a badge of honor.
Um,
people say,
you know,
she's amazing.
She's always on should it there and stacks and emails right away and we need to
change that.
We need to
change how we hear something like that.
So now if I hear someone say,
you know,
she's amazing.
She's always on,
I think,
ah,
that's a problem.
You know,
and it's a problem on many levels.
It's a problem because at some point that someone on person is going to burn out
mathematically and hot.
The farm,
the burnout decks will vary.
It can be a collapse like mine,
it can be a health issue.
Um,
it can be any number of things.
You know,
even a lot of the that happened that we think are accidents are really because
our immune system is down or we're not paying attention,
et cetera.
And the other thing is that you've,
this,
this whole building is like a celebration of creativity.
Youtube is sort of a celebration of creators.
So the first thing that gets degraded if you are sleep deprived is your
creativity.
You know,
you can still big transaction now you can still go to meetings and pay attention
with half your brain and make notes and um,
show up.
But really the part of you that really comes up with innovative game changing
ideas,
which is what you are all about,
is not functioning as well.
So we need to kind of rethink a whole idea of what it means to be optimally
performing.
And you know what?
I love that athletes who are all about performance and winning are now
prioritizing sleep and renewal and recharging.
I write a lot about Andrew Goodall in the book because he actually tracked his
stats after he started getting eight hours of sleep.
And it's just amazing to see the immediate impact on performance.
So sleep as a performance enhancer.
Now sleep is a lot more than that,
but I don't really care why he started getting enough sleep.
You know,
whatever your entry point is,
take it.
And one of the lines in the book is Com stump for the performance enhancing
benefits stay for the life enhancing benefits.
And for me the biggest life enhancing benefit is actually bringing joy into what
you're doing.
Because I feel we're also blessed to have jobs.
We love to be living here.
And so often enough for myself,
when I'm sleep deprived,
I may still get things done,
but the joy is gone.
I'm kind of drug,
I dragged myself through the day.
I just go through the motions.
But I'm not really a need.
Yes,
you're sleepwalking through through life,
but not really experiencing it.
Um,
I want to talk a little bit about media.
So I want to go back to a time when you certainly were not sleep walking through
anything.
When you,
um,
when you started the Huffington Post,
you started in 2005,
what do you think led it to become so successful when there were already a lot
of other online news platforms out there?
What was it about the Huffington Post that attracted so many readers?
So I think what it was is really what is at the heart of Youtube,
which is that we are a platform from the beginning.
Yes,
we are also a journalistic enterprise that a few years later won a Pulitzer and
we now have 850 journalists,
editors in 16 countries.
But the fact we were in a platform where people could come and create and tell
their stories and share them was really what differentiated us from the
beginning.
And that we did that not as a free for all,
but I'm making sure that the best things caught the most attention and that
there was no hierarchy except is this really worth them amplifying?
Is this worth sharing?
And whether it was President Obama or a homeless student who had something
interesting to say,
which actually happened.
And that homeless student wrote a beautiful blog post,
which happened to be seen by the Harvard admissions office and he's now in his
third year at Harvard.
So immediately use also the magic of what was happening in this digital
revolution that people were discovered.
And we look at all the,
all the stars that youtube has created.
Where would they be?
Were it not for this platform?
Um,
yeah,
the might get an agent in Hollywood,
Eh,
but now you don't need an agent in Hollywood.
A,
you don't need a publisher.
You can actually be your own publisher and you can be your own creator and you
can be discovered.
Yes.
I think there are a lot of similarities between the Huffington post as a
platform and youtube and it is all about just giving people a chance to have
their voice.
Um,
I was looking backwards to the,
to 2005 a lot has changed in the media industry.
What have you noticed over the last,
not just those 10 years,
but your history in the media industry and what do you think has happened is
going to happen next in the next five to 10 years of media?
So I think what's happening now as you know,
is that there's so much,
there's so many platforms,
there's so much noise that I think what is happening and where it's going to
become increasingly important in the next few years is are you adding value to
people's lives?
And a,
so I'd half paused or if deck and that too hard.
And we've divided everything we're doing into three editorial pillars.
The first is obviously news and politics,
but with our own perspective,
like we're not covering this election the way others are covering this election
from day one.
We refuse to treat Donald Trump as a normal candidate.
We feel this is very important for journalists not to buy into the idea that our
job is to be in the middle and presented two sides to the story.
Because you know what?
Not Everything has two sides.
You know,
evolution is a fact.
The earth is not flat.
Barack Obama was born in the United States.
You know,
global warming is real.
So and yet far too many journalists are having these conversations where you
have a scientist who believes in global warming.
Debating is scientist who doesn't as though this is a legitimate debate.
So from day one,
when Donald Trump decided he's running for president,
we started covering him in the entertainment center
on the ground.
Seth Meyers said that the White House correspondents dinner in 2011 when Donald
Trump first said he was running for president,
he said,
I just heard that Donald Trump is running for president as a Republican.
I thought he was running for president as a joke.
So the day that he actually pronounced this policy of banning 1.6 billion
Muslims from this country,
we stopped covering him in the entertainment section and we'll cover him as a
clear and present danger to this country.
And at the end of every story that mentions him,
there is an editor's note to them that says,
we want to remind our readers that Donald Trump wants to ban anti-religion from
this country,
is regularly inciting violence,
is a serial sexist,
misogynist,
and xenophobe who does not believe that the president of the United States was
born here.
And this is our job.
Our job is to keep reminding voters who he is.
Voters will do whatever they're going to do in November,
but it cannot be because the media have not done their job.
So as you can see,
the way we approach our politics and news pillar is very different.
The second pillar is covering solutions.
We think there's way too much coverage of problems and crisis and obviously we
cover those.
But there's an amazing amount of good happening in the world,
is an amazing amount of innovation and creativity and compassion.
And we need to cover those things too.
So we have a big editorial department called what's working and at the heart of
that is also encouraging people to take action.
And Susan and I have been talking about that,
how there's so much amazing stuff on youtube and how can we encourage people
immediately to take action because sometimes you,
you watch a video and you feel compelled to do something and then life
intervenes.
So if you don't do it right away,
it's going to be harder to do it.
So we're working with,
um,
crowdrise and we're working with Jordan and Houston's action baton and the glove
and poverty project button to make all these stories more action,
a Bot.
And the third thing is all our initiatives around wellness and reducing burnout
and all the things that we've been discussing in the first part of our
conversation.
Do you think the way that,
um,
that huff post and others will deliver that content,
interact with viewers and readers of that content,
will that change?
Would you see,
what do you see happening in the next five to 10 years in terms of how the media
works and how consumers are the media interact with it?
Well,
I think what's been happening is going to accelerate.
And of course you're right at the middle of this changes.
More and more of this content is going to be conceived on mobile.
More and more of it is going to be video and Mara Mara,
Mara rate is going to come to readers and viewers through the back door.
Instead of them going to a site,
it's going to be because their friends are sharing it,
um,
are some other social action that makes them aware of that content.
And we see that at,
they haven't done by setting the Huffington post properly,
the last major media side that still has destination traffic,
but we see declining every year.
So we've actually far postmark on or off platform traffic,
uh,
on the grounds that ubiquity is the new exclusivities what we're saying,
it's not really about exclusive content.
And we knew we love partnerships,
we love crossposting balls,
letting others crossbar style content and cross paths in the content of others.
So this is,
I think it's all these trends that are already present are going to accelerate
being where the people are and making it eats exactly.
Get to get 10.
And then also,
um,
shaping the content in ways appropriate probably for whatever platform you're
going to see their content because a lot of sense.
Um,
getting back to the news pillar just for a moment,
um,
I've would wonder,
what would you tell a young person today who is interested in getting into
journalism?
I would say golf.
I read and,
um,
Don Devon way to go to journalism school.
I just start where you are because journalism has so dramatically changed that
it's really about the stories you tell.
And then using the amazing technology available to step to tell these stories.
With Marlene packed,
we just bought a Vr company called riot.
Um,
and the reason we chose them is because they,
they care about,
um,
their stories having impact.
And now just using the technology to make a dog beauty fall and uh,
and um,
and appealing to people.
And so in the,
in the same sense,
if you had to go into journalism,
do have an impact,
whether they begged is in politics or entertainment or any field,
Eh,
this is the golden age of journalism.
It's a new style matters.
And in fact,
you have more tools as a journalist example to,
than ever before.
Okay.
Thank you.
Um,
I want to turn
to some questions about leadership.
Um,
so you have been phenomenally successful in such a variety of different areas,
but I'm sure along with everybody else,
you've had a lot of lessons along the way from setbacks,
et cetera.
Can you tell us about some of the lessons that you've learned both from the
success and from times where you've,
where you've struggled a bit?
Absolutely.
I,
I was very lucky that I had a mother when I was growing up in Athens,
Greece in a one bedroom apartment,
um,
with the no money who always made me believe that I could take risks in a,
it didn't matter if I fade,
because I think what stops us very often from taking risks and going for our
dreams,
he said,
we don't want to fail,
especially women.
For some reason.
We women want to be perfect and,
and uh,
we're an odd,
nobody is.
And so recognizing that failure my mother used to say,
isn't that the opposite of success,
whether a stepping stone to success and then instead of changes there we,
we are broad everything.
And for me I would say that the thing I've struggled the most all my life is,
um,
the voice inside my head that are called the obnoxious roommate living in my
head
that we all see our house.
Yes.
And,
and uh,
but you can really work on that voice and you can really make sure that that
voice only gets guest appearances and actually just to link it back to sleeve
when I'm sleep deprived,
which now I have to say only happens about 5% of the time,
um,
I,
that voice becomes intensified.
So that's another thing,
you know,
when we're arrested then recharge.
That voice doesn't have as much to way over us because we don't identify with
it.
And so that the voice of self doubt of questioning what we're doing is the most
draining thing in our lives.
So just if you notice it,
it's not really,
why do we do that's exhausting.
It's really what our mind does before and after,
before it's wearing,
like give you a deck.
Our conversation today,
you,
my mind beforehand can go into a worry anxiety.
Are they going to like what I'm seeing?
Am I going to remember everything I want to share?
You know,
all these things that are mind you mind does.
And then when we finish and win,
I love being here.
This is fun.
This is not work.
Uh,
I,
I talk about something.
I love your Fabry Lewis.
I'm meeting somebody new and uh,
and I look forward to your questions.
You know,
it's like great.
But if then I leave and my mind,
the obnoxious roommate starts with
maybe I'm catching what Susan has.
Um,
you know,
you forgot to say that.
Oh,
and the way you're talking about story,
I don't think it'd really worked.
And why did you wear that white jacket?
You know,
because it looks great.
It looks great,
but no,
no,
no.
What I'm saying?
Anybody that's on all the,
all new thing
switch.
I'm meaningless.
And is anybody recognizing the voice?
Yeah.
So let's just the whole kind of
make this decision that we don't take this very seriously.
It's not the truth.
It's not who we are.
We can just like treat it like a child.
You know,
when your child says something and it throws a temper Tantrum,
you don't have to actually act on it.
Right.
I shouldn't.
In fact,
especially the two and a half years
I ran,
I'm wanting to ask,
cause you also brought up your mother and um,
and her having teaching use it.
You could,
you could,
failure would be okay and that you as a woman,
um,
would still be able to succeed.
You've been a female leader in a very traditionally male dominated industry.
And this,
I know we have,
uh,
we have,
all sorts of folks here today,
but there are a lot of people from our women at group,
at Google here and a lot of people listening on the GVC.
So wondering if you have any advice for the women here and beyond Google who are
often in similar situation where they're in a male dominated industry.
How to,
how to think about showing up there?
Well,
I feel that we'll have a great opportunity as we were talking actually
beforehand for women,
not just to their,
our place at the top of the world in every profession had to actually including
the White House.
But to actually change the way the world works.
Because right now the way workplaces have been designed and the work of,
um,
the work world has been designed,
has been designed by men and it's not functioning well.
It's not really good for anybody,
including polar bears.
And,
and I think women have a greater opportunity to lead the way here.
So I feel it's not just about having the careers we want and knowing that we can
have any job and any position we want,
but also doing it differently because there's a lot of pain and suffering in the
world that we cannot immediately change.
But this is some pain and suffering that we can immediately change simply by
that cultural revolution that we are talking about,
of moving away from this delusion that we need to bear now to succeed.
And,
um,
men are going to be incredibly grateful because look at just last year alone,
the number of men who collapsed on their treadmills and either died or ended up
with heart attacks.
And because what's happening is that we've all kind of accepted whether we do it
or not,
that exercise and nutrition are important.
But the third pillar is sleep.
And you have all these sleep deprived Taipei executives getting up at the crack
of dawn to get the workout in when in fact I urge you to just sleep in,
you know,
when you're sleep deprived,
that's more important dealing with that deficit and then you'll have a lot more
energy even if you do a shorter workout or even if you skip it.
You just need to look at the science of how essential that is and all this
conversations happening in the workplace.
Um,
changing the way workplace or design of course that Google,
you know,
you're ahead of the curve,
but some of the other places are not.
Um,
I'm going to be key and I'd love women in whatever field they are to also take
that into account and do and to do it openly.
I mean,
I,
Susan an hour and Davos together and then we just happened to be sitting next to
each other at the dinner and she was telling me how she was pumping because she
had just had a fifth child and she said she goes back to their hotel and she'd
pumps and then she leaves it out in the snow because she didn't have a fridge.
Very creative to know,
well enough sleep to best read of idea.
And then I said,
well you have to dig a picture on Instagram.
Me,
they're sad because it would be so great for this.
And she did.
I don't know if you are salaried,
but it is so great to have this powerful kind of woman executive who is also a
mother and was bumping.
It should in these two grandmas have bumping.
She just
suggesting.
So Graham,
do you know the milk in the snow?
And,
and I think that the moral openly we men and navigate these,
there are different responsibilities and their mar,
they actually um,
make it a by ruthless prioritization rather than,
uh,
the juggling act that drives us all crazy.
Um,
the more we'd be able to change the culture faster.
Wonderful.
So we should be ourselves to bring ourselves to work a full full selves.
So my last question for you before I turn it over to the audience here into the
folks that have been asking questions on our dory,
um,
is really just this,
you have accomplished so much what is next for you.
So I didn't think there was going to be next after they haven't done past,
but in fact a thrive and the sleep revolution have led to so many amazing
conversations for me in so many companies and with so many people that have
decided to launch a new company,
thrive global,
which is going to be about going into corporations and helping them change the
culture around these principles and actually ending this a delusion that there
is a trade off between productivity and wellbeing and seeing that they do.
And in fact incredibly interconnected and making all our offerings,
trainings,
courses,
very science based and then measuring the impact of everything we are doing.
Um,
with this two key metrics,
um,
health care costs and productivity because I think the key to accelerating this
revolution is impacting the bottom line.
Absolutely.
And helping people recognize that in fact the wellbeing of employees is really
tied to the health of the bottom line and a pioneer.
Um,
in this area is Mark Bertolini,
the CEO of Aetna who is actually going to be joining the board of my comp new
company.
And I don't know if you saw the latest thing he's done.
He m he introduced this program at Aetna and even employees are given fitbit to
track their sleep and if they get seven hours or more for 20 nights and they are
given $300.
Wow.
So it's not just the financial incentive.
Can you imagine how revolutionary that is that the CEO of a fortune 500 company
is telling you that getting enough sleep is good for business?
Fantastic.
It's good for the shareholders.
And then he always brings in Duke University or some scientific center to
measure the impact on productivity and health care costs.
So for me,
that will will revolutionize how workplaces function and that will make it much
easier to change lives and reduce all that unnecessary pain and suffering.
Well we can't wait to see it and we will make sure that you get to talk to
Sundar Lazlo and I lean about this idea of
thank you.
I know that I would love to invite folks from the audience here in San Bruno to
come up to the mix with any questions for Ariana.
We'll first take one live here and then we'll go to our dory.
Any brave souls?
Want to ask Ariana a question and let us know.
I'm sorry there's a mic right and you probably can't see it.
It's right in the sort of middle of the room over here and let us know your name
and if you're doing,
if you want,
you can tell us how many hours sleep.
Yep.
Last night,
last night,
if you want to say how much you got last night,
is it on?
I just didn't get enough last night.
I'm,
I'm Aaron.
So I lead our product team for consumer music area and I'm actually working on
trying to get more sleep.
But it's really hard.
Um,
my question for you,
you touched on earlier,
um,
you know,
how the post is covering the election and taking more of a perspective of
sometimes there isn't two sides to a story.
And what I've,
and I'm and it's been talked about is how people can very easily now find
content that reinforces their own views.
And so there's sort of this echo chamber where instead of,
um,
going to a sort of central new stores,
people just,
you know,
share things and it seems to be driving more of a divide in opinion,
public opinion.
And so I'm curious what you think,
what are some of the things that we can do to,
um,
to impact that in a positive way?
Because it seems to be driving people to more extreme point of view,
extreme points of view.
And I'm curious your thoughts on that.
Thank you.
Well,
first of all,
before I answer that,
can I give you just one very,
very simple tape about guessing mostly sounds great
and since you have the book,
you'll see the second part of the book is all about best practices and simple
tips and techniques.
But please don't go straight to that because they're key thing is to convince
yourself by Lou reading all the latest scientific findings of how important it
is.
Because once you change your mind about it's important,
it will be easier to change your habits.
But the Marston Barder nonnegotiable thing is creating a little transition to
sleep.
That's what we've lost in modern times.
So you still have young children so you know that you don't just drop your child
in bed some nights.
You may wish to wish you give it a bath,
you put it in as PJ's using it the lullaby.
So we needed or the equivalent with ourselves,
age,
each person's ritual with different,
but it's kind of creating your own good night moon,
you know,
good night,
loved up goodnight,
goodnight smartphone,
us,
got them out of your bedroom.
That's the first kid thing,
you know,
because we're all addicted to our devices,
let's admitted so they have to slip separately from you.
And that's the first kind of nonnegotiable tip.
And then there are many,
many,
many others.
But creating that little ritual,
even if you start with a five,
10 minute demarcation line between your day life without are inevitable
challenges and obstacles and incompletions and the time for us to sleep and
recharge minus 30 minutes now,
and I describe it in the book,
it's going to make an incredible difference.
So bad politics.
Um,
I feel that that's definitely an issue.
But I think the bigger issue is that we are losing respect for facts.
You see,
I think that it's perfectly okay to have divergent opinions,
but we cannot have a different set of facts that we based this opinion on song.
So when Hillary Clinton in her speech yesterday,
he said,
I believe in science,
that should not be a point of between two candidates.
And I think that's really where we need to be kind of much more adamant and much
more absolute,
you know,
why does,
why does the fact behind this opinion and I think that we help close the divide
we're experiencing right now.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm going to take a question from our,
because we've got so many people around the globe interested in seeing this and
asking you questions.
So here's one that we have,
which is what role Ariana do you see live streaming playing in all media in the
future.
Okay.
And in general,
what's,
what has driven your decision,
um,
to either leverage an industry platform versus build one yourself?
And the example here that the question asker gave was,
um,
you spent,
I,
of course last question.
You spent resources to build a player for Huffpo live,
um,
instead of utilizing a free solution.
So how do you decide to build yourself versus use somebody else's?
And how important do you think live is?
So we think life is more and more important and we're very,
in fact,
we consider it to Susan doing part of this conversation on your new offering,
eh,
your live offering.
We're doing a lot with Facebook live.
We're doing a lot on snapchat and we also have our own huffpost live.
So again,
we're very agnostic.
We want to be on every platform and we want to be on every platform,
um,
in ways that are appropriate to that platform.
And so for example,
for one day we took cover,
um,
a pop up discover channel on snapchat called it recharge and it was all around
sleep and recharging and um,
it was amazing.
It was like funny.
It was all about,
um,
kind of message that would appeal to millennials and would not be kind of Etl
Broccolini and make it sexy and fun and give them all the stats about how I'm
getting enough sleep.
Um,
deals with Eric,
dial dysfunction,
for example.
Did you know that?
And so may made it appropriate to the platform and it had incredible engagement.
So that's why we,
we need to be agnostic to the platform instead of expecting us all expecting
everybody to go to half of us live.
But you think live is increasingly important you guys are investing in.
Absolutely.
And I think live stream is very important and even live events and incredibly
important.
You not remember there was a time when we thought nobody would go to anything
life.
And you know,
all of you could be watching this on live stream but you chose to come here.
So I think live stream is going to be more and more important and live events
will we always be important because especially the more technology dominates our
before the more we actually still want that.
That direct connection.
Yes.
Thank you.
We will take questions from the ground.
Hi Arianna.
My name is Scott.
I'm on the partnerships team here at Youtube and last night I slept for six
hours.
Um,
so piggybacking off of the last live question,
um,
in this presidential election where you have a lot of the rhetoric on one side
being based around fear and anger and not around facts,
which is something that you were saying Hillary Clinton was trying to reinforce
the fact that she believes in science,
it's hard to believe that that's the argument that we're making in 2016.
So what sort of role and responsibility to be play in media companies like
Huffington Post,
youtube,
other platforms around the world in combating fear and anger and things that are
emotion based and so strongly emotionally based as opposed to things that aren't
rooted.
In fact,
what I love the fact that Susan called on everybody to,
um,
do use the platform to express their views.
Uh,
you know,
after all this explosion of violence and to actually recognize that you are
offering a very,
very powerful Tori and more and more people,
um,
need to use it.
And so this is not a time to sort of sit things out.
And then for me,
this election will be decided in the end by who?
By who turns out to vote.
And,
uh,
so anything that the platform can do to reinforce that,
you don't have to tell them how to vote obviously,
but to a,
to make them recognize that this is not an election to sit out and say,
you know,
I don't really like any either of the candidates very much,
eh,
because
this is a,
this is really an existential threat to our democracy and people need to take a
stance and they can take a stance obviously by creating content,
by expressing themselves,
um,
by sharing things that they feel,
express their point of view and by voting.
And the more we can get that message out to all the different demographics that,
um,
that are on youtube and the Mall Bosley,
we can influence the outcome.
Thank you.
I can speak for Google and say,
and Youtube and say that we are very committed to using our resources to help
get out the vote.
So there'll be a lot of efforts here in the u s on youtube and across Google to
make sure that people get to get out to vote and express their opinions.
That's fantastic.
And I'm saying,
you know,
I'm on the board of Oba and we're having a board meeting yesterday and we're
talking about free Uber Rides to go to Poles,
whatever.
Maybe airbnb can,
if you have to fly to travel to another city to vote,
maybe I'll be in beacon help subsidize where you stay,
sort of basically every company needs to do what they can to encourage people to
vote because it's absurd how many millions and millions of people did not vote
in the last election.
If we can change that,
um,
it'll have a huge impact on our democracy.
So I'm very happy to hear that.
Absolutely.
Um,
changing gears a little bit,
back to wellness,
and this is something you and I talked about this morning,
so I really,
I really want you to share your point of view here.
I'm a question.
The question that we have from the,
from somebody outside the offices,
um,
it seems easy to advocate for slowing down and getting seven to eight hours of
sleep once you've made it.
But how do you counter the perception that you have to put in time and sleep
deprivation before earning the ability to have a work life and sleep balance?
Well,
thank you so much for asking this question because my obnoxious roommate,
if we had not dealt with this topic,
would have told me afterwards you should have addressed that fact because that
is a very important fact and that's exactly what has led to the founder meet.
You know,
the idea that if you're the founder of a company or if you're starting in your
career,
you have to out outwork everybody and just,
um,
pay your dues and all these things and it is scientifically fault.
That doesn't mean that a lot of people who've succeeded haven't been sleep
deprived and exhausted along the way it is because up until now,
everybody,
since the first industrial revolution has been living and working under this
delusion,
but it is not only unnecessary but counterproductive.
So,
let me just give you an example.
We all know the stats.
Three quarters of startups fail,
start up,
founders are exhausted and sleep deprived.
Hey,
maybe there's a correlation here.
Maybe we can change the stat because there's not question that our cognitive
performance is degraded when we're exhausted.
So that's why understanding the science is so key to changing that cultural
perception.
There is actually a great study that came out in the Harvard business review by
Mckinsey to late to include in my book,
but it will be the paperback and my kids is study and the title you would have
thought it was out of the army on the tidal was the proven link between
effective leadership and sleep.
Now can you imagine that studied like even two years ago.
Um,
and they walk you through on the science of what happens to your prefrontal
cortex when you are sleep deprived and how it affects your decision making and
how it affects your capacity to lead and to be empathetic and to build teams and
to spire and all the things that are essential to leaders.
Absolutely.
I think we have another question here in San Bruno.
Hi,
Ariana.
Uhm,
I'm Daniel from the living room team.
I got about seven hours of sleep last night.
All right.
Um,
so I was curious your thoughts if you had any,
uh,
recently it's come out that Peter Thiel,
who is a luminary figure in the valley,
but not,
not without controversy,
has been bankrolling a number of lawsuits against Gawker media.
Um,
the supreme court has told us that money equals speech,
so he's certainly entitled to do as he wishes,
but I'm curious if you had thoughts on one billionaire trying to take down a
media company,
irrespective of whether it's a muckraker side or,
or whatnot.
So,
so,
um,
I actually believe that it's not the role of billionaires to,
to try and take down sides.
Um,
I think eight is even more dangerous when billionaires running for president
talk about banishing media.
And I think that's really infinitely more dangerous.
And,
and Donald Trump has said many times that,
um,
not only are he demonstrated already by removing credentials from the Huffington
Post,
from the Washington Post,
for many,
eh,
media operations that,
uh,
I have taken very strong stances against.
Seymour simply point out the facts.
You know,
again,
it's that the Washington Post stories that made him subset,
you know,
we're not even,
we're not opinion driven.
They were fact driven.
Um,
as you know,
Beto de Alonso speaking at the convention and it sounded that,
I don't understand or tall,
maybe he did not read the platform on gay rights,
Eh,
but you know,
people just need to try and build more consistent,
um,
about,
all these issues.
And so I ultimately,
freedom of expression includes acknowledging that a lot of things being
expressed are not going to be to my liking.
Thank you.
We have another question coming up here in San Bruno.
Hi.
Hello.
Ariella.
Um,
my name's Ariana from the people operations team.
I'm a huge fan of yours.
I've been reading the huffpost since 2005 so read it everyday.
Yeah.
And I,
last night,
I think I got seven hours,
but usually,
um,
what I'm trying to go to sleep,
I'm usually reading the Huffington post,
but I'll try to read it like around nine and then the break between the two.
Um,
okay.
so first off,
thank you so much for coming.
It's great to see you in person.
Um,
so I have a question about the media.
So,
um,
it was reported I think in 2000,
or excuse me,
in March,
2016 that a Bush or not pushed,
um,
that,
uh,
sorry,
I'm a little nervous.
It was reported by the New York Times that,
uh,
Trump had almost $2 billion of free media coverage.
And then,
um,
a couple of other things that have been interesting as like in the 2000
presidential election,
the media declared Bush the winter before the votes in Florida where even
counted.
And then,
um,
also this last election cycle,
I was a little upset when I'm California,
hadn't voted yet,
and the media declared a Clinton the winner of the,
um,
uh,
democratic nomination.
So I'm just curious what your thoughts are about like the political kind of
manipulation that's happening with the media and how they're kind of changing
public opinion and things like that.
And maybe how we can counter that.
Well,
the absolutely great question.
And,
uh,
I,
I'm very troubled by the media role in especially in this election cycle.
There was actually a great style by the Sharon Center at Harvard about how
effectively and the media,
um,
dramatically help Donald Trump win the nomination because at the beginning when
they were giving him this amazing amount of coverage that as you said,
was the equivalent of $2 billion in free advertising.
There was no justification for it.
She was not ahead in the polls.
He had not built the kind of fundraising organization,
um,
teams that,
would make him a legitimate candidate.
So just,
just purely because of ratings.
And they even allowed him to phone in to major political shows,
including the Sunday shows,
which never happens.
And,
uh,
and so a lot of what the media have been doing has been ratings driven
rather than driven by,
Eh,
basic journalistic ethics.
And we've done a lot of coverage on that again and again.
And um,
it's also a recognition
that for me came very much to the forefront when I was giving a commencement
speech at um,
uh,
Fletcher,
which is in foreign service school at Tufts.
And it also houses the Edward Murrow papers.
And I was talking to the head of the morrow center about how would he have
handled Donald Trump.
And he said he wouldn't have skewered here.
And if you go back and see how morrow handed McCarthy,
this is not the time to actually hold back and far too many journalists,
even the way they are covered in this,
this conventions,
Eh,
you know,
focusing on things that are legitimizing,
um,
the entire Shah raid of the Trump candidacy.
M shows that these are all ratings driven decisions and nothing has,
I don't think there is some deep manipulation behind these decisions except that
when Donald Trump was and meet the press,
it was the biggest rating bonanza that chuck Todd had.
Thank you.
I'll check it out is not letting him call in anymore.
And I'll be very proud of chuck,
who's one of my favorite journalists.
Um,
one last question Ariana,
cause we're at the end of our time,
sadly.
Um,
but I want to get back to wellness and thrive.
So one last question from,
uh,
from here was how important is napping to productivity and well being and have
you seen examples of napping being incorporated and integrated successfully into
a company's culture?
Yes.
So first of all,
not being is incredibly important.
I if you've gotten all the sleep you need,
which just to remind you is seven to nine hours unless you have a genetic
mutation,
which is only one in a hundred people.
So you are unlikely to have that much.
I'm sure one or two of you here do.
And you know that and if you don't know that you can test yourself.
Um,
but having said that,
um,
napping is amazing.
So if you didn't get enough sleep for whatever reason and that's all it's going
to happen.
You have a sick child,
do you have a big deadline,
your flight was late and then try and get a nap as soon as possible.
In the day,
even a 20 minute nap is unbelievably restorative.
Winston Churchill regularly napped and won the Second World War and call them
power naps at the half and imposter of two nap rooms and they're always full.
And now here you have a lot of Napa judge.
We do and nap rooms in almost every office.
Yes,
Youtube,
you have an appro we do.
Great.
Does everybody know where the now pro pods and rooms,
right?
So I think that I'm predicting that within the next five years,
the nap room is going to be as universal as the conference room in every
company,
not just
pioneering companies like Google and youtube.
So the,
the thing that we need to recognize is that even the middle of the afternoon or
at any point you,
you feel really tired,
there's nothing that's going to increase your productivity as fast as a little
nap.
And um,
it's going to dramatically transform how we handling this afternoon.
Low Pints were normally,
now we go for the Fifth Cup of coffee or a donut or whatever it is to,
to get some energy.
So this is all part of the culture change that is happening and that I have with
your help and me,
you're amazing creators and leaders and in our culture.
So you have an incredible power to accelerate,
a cultural change that's already happening and that's going to bring some
amazing change in people's lives and,
and would love to hear from you and the Huffington Post.
You can send me anything you want,
Arianna Huffington post.com we'd love to post it and I'm,
of course we can cross paths with Andy or including on that Liddy plus from you
work phone calls.
Well Ariana,
we cannot wait to see what you do with thrive.
Thank you so much for being with us here,
right
today.
Please give him a round of applause.
Do you?
Yeah.
Thank you.
I honor
in your honor.
Let's all try to get seven to nine hours of sleep tonight beyond everyone.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.